no I'm not growing a Viking beard I've
just had a long week the girl who died I
was a little bit nervous going into this
one due to the period setting because
historical set ones tend to not be my
favorites but this was pretty good I
mean elephant in the room before I get
into spoilers it is not as good as the
last two stories of this series happen
but it is still pretty good see what
bugs me about most of the historical
setup so is this they tend to either get
really bogged down in a specific
historical figure who may or may not be
played as a caricature or the approach
that they take to the alien aspect gets
real old real quick with things like say
vampire in London or the black spot or
even hide with things like who it's
vampires it's a siren it's ghost but
what is it really well we know what it
is really this is Doctor Who it's aliens
so I like that this episode nips a lot
of that in the but by setting inviting
times are not dealing with any specific
his famous historical figure and we are
right off the bat not dealing with any
alien that's trying to pass itself off
as a piece of mythology I mean we are
you know the guy claims to be Odin but
we know immediately like well duh that's
an alien just projecting his face in the
clouds so sorry takes the curse off the
normal stumbling blocks that these
episodes tend to have for me and I like
the tone of it this is a more
lighthearted episode and I think it's
important for Doctor Who to have more
lighthearted episodes if things can get
iffy when it devolves into outright
comedy and then we can end up with stuff
like love and monsters but a light tone
with a sense of fun that this really has
that going I mean the consequence of
that is indeed does not feel as
substantial as the last two stories that
we've gotten but not everything should
be that heavy we should have a palate
cleanser every now and then a lot always
this feels like that and it's funny with
good doctor who want to get wrapped up
in it that I tend to forget stuff that I
already knew going in like it happened
last season with dark water I I forgot
that Cybermen were showing up I mean
that had been part of the early trailers
wait before the series started we hadn't
seen them yet I should have known they
were coming but I forgot when they
showed up I was surprised and it was
awesome this one for some reason I
forgot the title the girl who died so
when she keeled over dead I was like
oh but that's a sign of really good
storytelling it makes you forget the
stuff that maybe you already knew
because you're just wrapped up in it I
really like that we finally got a tie
into an explanation as to the doctors
face and why he looks like Kye Kelley
as' and I like it it's not like some
deep hugely profound oh this changes
everything revelation but it's like it's
simple as that this is a reminder to
yourself you're not just there to stop
the bad things from happening you're
there to save people that is sort of
reminder to himself it's small it's
subtle it borrows a moment of Donna
who's my favorite companion so that
didn't hurt either it was nice I like
the answer that we got I like the way
that we got it it was a good moment if
I'm gonna lay any criticisms out of this
thing it's it's gotta be two things
basically the first is it just seemed to
happen more often I had a hard time
understanding what the doctor and Clara
were saying at times and this isn't the
first time that's happening but it
seemed like it happened more often in
this episode than is normal the other
thing is sort of the end resolution with
Maisie Williams character who I did like
and was fine I think it got hyped up a
little more than it was worth because
you know Maisie Williams Game of Thrones
and she's awesome on that and I love her
on that but I mean you know this part
was at least as it appeared in this
episode you know it wasn't like oh that
was nice part she was good for him
we'll see what happens later and we'll
get to that in a second but the whole
moment that he takes with the oh she's a
hybrid and that calling back to the
notion of a prophecy that was mentioned
in the first story I think was the
witch's familiar specifically that they
brought it up it I actually didn't talk
about that getting mentioned in that
episode because I chose to ignore it I
really really hate prophecies as a
storytelling device they're lazy they're
cheap shortcut and I really just don't
like them and if this does feed back
into that I don't like it because like
hybrid is such a vague term it could
mean any number of things I mean we have
seen multitudes of creatures throughout
the history of the show that all qualify
as hybrid I would think that the human
hybrid Daleks from Daleks and Manhattan
will be a much better fit for calling
something a hybrid just this girl's got
a tiny bit of alien
Tech in her head I mean come on that
sort of thing is a dime a dozen and the
Doctor Who universe to imply that oh she
fits this prophecy was something that
does not feel like it's that uncommon in
this universe heads dad I don't like
that as far as where things will go and
how it'll pan out next episode I'm not
sure I will say I do like that this
wasn't really a two-parter it told a
complete story but it left a strand for
us to pick up and run with later and I
kind of liked that overall I did like
this episode despite my little nitpicky
things there were a lot of individual
moments that I liked mostly you know
lighter brevity based moments I really
liked that when the doctor finally came
up with his plan and he's telling them
you know how to set up and how to go
about things he's basically describing
his own philosophy of life you know
winning is looking happier than the
other guy Quito act like you already
know their plan and sometimes when
you're lucky they will tell it to you
it's like that's just how you go about
you're like him just saying it out loud
it was just it was fun it was funny it
was off-the-cuff for a hammond which
just felt right felt appropriate and
there's a lot of little moments like
that sprinkled throughout this episode
it's light its breezy it's fun so what
were your thoughts on the girl who died
and what are your thoughts on the hybrid
prophecy things do you think it will
actually turn out to be her because if
we resolve her story at the end of the
next episode with Lynne that seems
pretty early to resolve something that
felt like a seed being planted for later
oh and I want to mention something else
just to see if this pans out I wanted on
records is anyone else noticing a sort
of a theme of stories and storytelling
something just rang about that with me I
mean obviously with Maisie Williams
character in this she sort of uses the
her nature as a storyteller to help beat
these aliens and it just reminded me of
the doctor's lines of the Fisher King
this is where your story ends just that
that word choice I don't like to think
that that's coincidental I'm wondering
if that whole notion of stories and the
power of stories stories ending stories
beginning is gonna be something that we
see throughout the series I kind of hope
so I'm a sucker for stories about
stories but in any case whatever your
thoughts were on any of this drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned